bonsoir mesdames bon sens mesdemoiselles
messieurs bonsoir
dans cette émission qui commence de quoi
sera-t-il question est bien bien entendu
des affaires de la france c'est-à-dire
du référendum qui commence demain matin
dans certains endroits même à partir de
6 heures du matin sur le territoire
métropolitain de la continuation du
référendum en algérie et aussi
malheureusement pour le joueur sera
obligé de au toucher de moore des
atteintes à dieu léon léon zitrone nous
a quittés hier soir le jour même de ses
81 ans en milieu de semaine il avait été
hospitalisé au val de grâce à paris pour
une hémorragie cérébrale avec léon
zitrone
c'est le mans ce sacré de l'âge d'or de
la télévision qui disparaît journaliste
animateur d' intervilles commentateurs
de courses de chevaux de mariages et des
enterrements des grands de ce monde
il savait presque tout faire dans un
style et avec une voix si particulière
benoît duquesne les enfants je suis très
content de vous revoir après ces courtes
vacances scolaires et le sujet de la
classe aujourd'hui ma voix je le possède
bien il s'agit de môssieur léon zitrone
monsieur zitrone avait deux passions
dans sa vie la télé et son épouse laura
chéri est ce que tu veut m'envoyer le
trench s'il te plaît le vert le vieux
oui on l'appelait le gros léon c'était
une institution à la télé et il le
savait il faisait partie de ces monstres
du petit écran qui sont passés et du
noir et blanc à la couleur qui ont
traversé toutes les époques sans jamais
altérer bonsoir mesdames bon sens
mesdemoiselles messieurs bonsoir
dans cette édition qui commence de quoi
serait-il question et zitrone entre
d'abord à la rtf en 48 avant d'intégrer
l'équipe du journal télévisé en 56 3 ans
plus tard il devient présentateur
maintenant venir
il le restera jusqu'en 75 cas où 1300
journaux télévisés avec au credo la
rigueur l'honnêteté la sobriété zitrone
était avant tout un professionnel même
s'il disait n'avoir aucune spécialité
mais je chante si vous permettez
l'expression
ma spécialité c'est justement de ne pas
en avoir des spécialités zitrone on
avait pourtant plusieurs à commencer par
la russie
il y était né en 1914 d'un père
teinturier il parlait la langue et on
était fier rideau ricci dont vous parlez
un peu le français
mais très bien je crois un peu timide
mais c'est pourquoi ne croyez vous pas
que la guerre puisse éclater sont notre
spécialité c'était les grandes seconde
qu'ils soient chefs d'état prince roi il
les a tous côtoyer les a mariés enterré
il n'y avait pas de grande cérémonie
sans les commentaires de léon zitrone de
la reine victoria ou chapeau - ian
wilson un anneau de cuir ou pas ses
larmes achkhabad et chevaux c'est bien y
trône groupies qui collectionnait les
autographes
je viens de php h
tous les logos de lui
bourgeois zitrone et ses fiches si l'on
préparait des centaines pour commenter
un événement et il s'en moquait il faut
que je vous demande quelques secondes
pour essayer de me retrouver dans mes
notes
on ne peut pas toujours réparer et
préparé par dans son reportage
comme l'ong allons-y tron a tous fait
des courses de chevaux en passant par
intervilles il sait tout permis parce
qu'il pouvait le faire
ses colères légendaires et son caractère
soupe-au-lait n'y changeront rien on
aimait y trône comme il aimait les gens
peuplé course à auteuil à longchamp
n'importe où les voici
quel est votre plus beau souvenir de en
tant que commentateur sportif as en tant
que commentateur sportif les jeux
olympiques de montréal en 1976 drut a
gagné les le 110 m haies et je ne
pensais pas pouvoir raconter ma vie sur
13 secondes
alors j'ai commencé comme ça à jusqu'au
bout en bourse en avril il a gagné
léon zitrone s'est éteint hier soir au
val-de-grâce il avait 81 en juillet 1993
zitrone qui était déjà en retraite
officielle de télévision et est revenu
sur france 2 pour commenter les obsèques
du roi baudouin de belgique à cette
occasion il avait en quelque sorte
délivrer son propre testament écoutons
le truculent plutôt très grande car ekpe
rougeau et l'apparence joyeuse lebel
j'aime bien ma vie et prend toujours les
choses du bon côté et nous revoyons une
énième fois la 6è le vent du panais
je ne me souviens pas d'avoir vu des
écriteaux semblable et je finis presque
ma vie professionnelle ici on me
pardonnera je l'espère je vous le
demande
l'émotion qui à certains moments pour m
submergées on ne peut pas toujours
totalement bribes et ses sentiments
la télévision c'est la vie mon dieu
comme le temps passe vite comme la vie
nous empêche
d'en profiter pleinement comme les
choses s'enchaînent aux autres et comme
nous devons subir de rythme
ils étaient vingt jeunes chiens
aujourd'hui je suis arrivé dans la force
de l'âge et même un peu au-delà
j'arrive presque à la fin de ma carrière
encore 3,4 et ses émissions et j'irai
planté mais le chou mais la conclusion
que je tire de mon existence et de celle
des gens d'à peu près ma génération
c'est que cela va trop vite les arbres
en fleurs du plein été contraste avec le
deuil qui passe pour la génération de
l'après-guerre qui a vu la naissance
puis l'éclatement de la télévision en
france la vedette c'était léon zitrone
un jour face à khrouchtchev le lendemain
sur une piste de patinage le
surlendemain saint-amand-les-eaux pour
commenter intervilles réaction donc ce
matin de français dans la rue allent
annonce de la nouvelle jacques cardoze
stéphane chopin
je crois que l'iran un tournant dès que
le dire c'était un des meilleurs et ua à
l'eau airtel et sémantique avait dit que
le change pour mu
qui savent elles doivent montrer un
grand homme
on aimait bien les reportages sur les
mariages princiers ça se ferait avec les
liens des vrais le 14 juillet aussi et
les courses aussi dire beaucoup de
reportages sur les courses
ah oui jusqu'à 100 m du poteau
même si orale était avant-dernier qu'on
avait joué on y croyait encore citer
tous les chevaux en même temps c'était
avec nous à vous faire plaisir quand il
commençait les courses étaient fous on y
croyait au début jusqu'à la fin même si
notre cheval n'était pas ce que dernier
quoi qu'est-ce que vous appréciez
particulièrement lorsque vous
l'entendiez souffrir y est essentielle
dans sa conversation il était juste et
je vais bien c'était encore dans le coup
le milieu audiovisuel quelqu'un que
j'apprécie il avait l'air sincère je
pense qu'on devrait prendre son exemple
autour de nous des invités bien sûr que
nous allons interroger ils ont connu
comme élève ou que m léon zitrone mais
d'abord pierre tchernia qui fait lui
aussi partie des pionniers de la
télévision il nous rappelle en quoi les
onze itron correspondaient très
exactement à son époque entretien
nicolas cornu l'angle à mon avis il a dû
arriver au journal en 54 moi j étais en
49 quand on a créé avec sa bague et il a
dû arriver au journal en 54 il est
devenu très vite célèbre parce que sa
bague l'a fait venir pour commenter des
courses de chevaux qui était une chose
totalement nouvelle qui connaissait très
bien et il est devenu célèbre il s'est
imposé et il avait déjà 40 ans donc
j'étais journaliste nouveau en fête avec
une grande expérience professionnelle
la grande période de gloire de léon
zitrone
ce sont les années 60 les années 60
c'est pour dire
elle les années les années du gaullisme
le billet par pompidou a dit les
journalistes de la télévision sont la
voix de la france alors il avait cette
merveilleuse apparence marmoréenne cette
voix de bronze une part d'air france est
très pure
il parlait beaucoup d'anglais d'abord et
très bien le français
alors il est devenu une sorte de maître
de cérémonie
de la télévision il représentait la
télévision une télévision de cette
époque là qui n'avait pas le goût de la
provocation
nous avons en partage maintenant et qui
était une télévision respectueuse dit on
peut dire un peu compassé
mais c'était l'image de la télévision de
ce temps là on n'a pas le juger c'était
ça le jeune gay est ce que vous partagez
la vie de pierre cheney c'était la
télévision ce temps là oui tout à fait
c'est vrai c'est moi ce que je retiens
de de léon zitrone d'abord cesser cette
silhouette s'il allait beaucoup faire
des cures d'amaigrissement faisait 100
kg il avait ce timbre de voix qui
transperçait l'écran ses lunettes il a
été le premier personnage ronde la
télévision il s'appelait léon il avait
alain chemin il avait s'était pas commun
ils avaient à la fois le respect des
grands de ce monde ils pouvaient
s'adresser à gorbatchev à khrouchtchev
et à la reine elizabeth et commencé
commenté une course de vachettes avec
guy lui dans les arènes de
saint-amand-les-eaux
moi je lui dois beaucoup de choses je
dois beaucoup de chose à des gens de
cette génération
d'ailleurs c'est tout à fait fait très
émouvant pour moi vous m'avez assis à
côté jacqueline baudrier et et sa
vieille prison yvan mahé qui a beaucoup
fait également prendre parcours
personnel mais ça c'est une autre
histoire
lewin a présenté il ya 30 ans jour pour
jour un soir de janvier à 8h20 dans ce
port dimanche il faut quand même savoir
qu'à l'époque en 64 65 y avait quatre
millions et demi de postes à peu près 13
à 15 millions téléspectateurs
on faisait le plein évidemment tout le
temps il y avait qu une serre charmeur
et blanc et sportivement je suivais le
journal de 20h présenté par léon et
précédé le film du dimanche soir moi je
suis passé entre la fin du journal de
l'est ont présenté par lui dans ce port
dimanche y changer plateau et avant la
vache et le prisonnier d'henri verneuil
il m'a présenté j'étais terrorisée j'ai
21 ans il y avait les ondes à côté il y
avait coderre de l'autre je tremblais
comme une feuille
je suis resté huit minutes à tremblay
minutes comme ça on m'avait pas dit
qu'il fallait mettre les mains à plat il
ya encore des gens qui trente ans après
se souviennent de ce parrainage ce
double parrainage de léon et de roger
couderc ce qu'il faut aussi parler de
ranger qui était très très lié
il a participé à la grande invention
d'intervilles ranger donc moi je retiens
cette polyvalence et puissance de
travail
nominale il parlait plusieurs langues et
tchernia raison de le rappeler mais
qu'est-ce qui parlait bien notre langue
lui mais à petrograd c'est quelqu'un qui
a travaillé comme un fou et qui avaient
une conscience professionnelle que j'ai
rarement vu moi j'ai vu je n'ai vu faire
les 14 km du parcours des otages est
cherchent ils à londres pour se rendre
au camp avec l'assistant du radiateur la
bbc demandé où étaient les caméras
qu'est-ce qu'elle risquait de balayer
pour ne pas rater un plan de coupe d'une
façade michel vous avez des élèves de
léon zitrone et jacqueline baudrier vous
avez été contemporaine de 11 y trône
vous avez été sa directrice de
l'information pourquoi vous est-il tout
se permettre sans jamais vrai sans
jamais être ridicule parce qu'ils
connaissaient une métier il aimait le
métier il avait une fois dans ce métier
que peu atteignent finalement et il
était perfectionniste il était il avait
le goût comme vous l'avez dit de la
langue française s'explique et devient
la précision la rigueur il avait une
très forte personnalité qui crevait
l'écran qui faisait qu' on a entendu les
les témoins tout à l'heure le grand
public l'homme et la femme de la rue qui
gardent vitraux des souvenirs qu'ils
méritent qu'on garde parce que se donner
autant de mal pour s'inviter cetera il
faisait 200 fiches je crois qu'il a fait
200 fiches pour les obsèques
beaudoin moi je me souviens la première
fois que j'ai aperçu c'est trop c'était
dans les studios de la radio
il appartenait à ce moment il faisait
ses débuts je crois il appartenait aux
éditions françaises vers l'étranger et
il faisait vers le canada en particulier
des émissions religieuses
on entendait des clash des clashs
déclaré ans une voix de stentor
extraordinaire une chose près alors
soyons clairs mais si jacques une volée
de juvisy secondes oui non mais on est
haut par les rues et les eaux il y
faisait un dimanche comme aujourd'hui
il présentait le journal que vous
présentez il manger rapidement that up
where were une salade de tomates
présentés par préparé par sa femme dans
les contre-allées dali bosquet il allait
auteuil commentait le tiercé
il revenait faire le journal de 20
heures il changer de plateau pour faire
le tiercé et il fermer l'antenne avec
télé mais c'était la cité une journée
normale de lyon on va retrouver nos
invités juste après soyons clairs je
viens de le dire à l'instant dans sa
carrière léon zitrone s'est permis des
choses qui je le disais en or
utilisez plus d'un d'entre nous lui s'en
est toujours sorti avec brio notamment à
l'occasion des fameux intervilles
c'était en compagnie de guy lux on
écoute de guy lux interrogé par john
paul lepers
quand on dit c'est léon c'est toute la
télévision dans ces exagérations dans
son talent dans ses connaissances dans
sa culture dans son humour car il aime
beaucoup dans ces mauvais dans ses
colères donc sa mauvaise humeur
peu d'hommes peuvent réunir autant de
choses à la fois est resté aussi
populaire qui les cas finalement lyon
est un homme à réchy populaire il a
laissé un souvenir absolument
ineffaçable glee quand je dis et je les
dis je et je vous le répète à vous pour
moi la perte de léon représente pour la
télévision une perte aussi grande
toutes proportions gardées que la paire
du général de gaulle pour la france
c'est parce que la télévision est en
deuil
elle a perdu son personnage elle a perdu
sans son symbole presque je pense
qu'elle est on aurait dû être comme
molière dû mourir en scène devant une
caméra avril se dire s'arrêtait plus
beau cadeau qui est là que la télévision
a pu faire on lui a pas fait c'est
dommage
nous l'avons dit léon zitrone a été
l'homme à tout faire de l'ovaire tf il
aimait la télévision et les
téléspectateurs le lui rendait bien il y
avait donc le journaliste léon zitrone
et puis les autres facettes du
personnage en voici quelques-unes un
sens gare saint charles à gauche dans
cette voiture et celle qui était la
camarade de jeu et de sortie de ton
frère andrew à droite il dit aux
chandelles charles et diana et lui dit
oui qui attend et ce sera presque
aussitôt le communiqué plombe payant ou
l'arrêt dé philippe laisse éclater
d'envoi consomme en sprint il leur fils
bien-aimé bien d'émettre sa famille et
bien aimée de la poule
vous le sentez par des acclamations
lewenza
la voici on découvre enfin sa robe
il fait de pure soie ivoire avec du
taffetas et des dentelles avec des
broderies faites à la main et et des
soutiens en perdez vous savez que le
premier soir on l'a vu sortir
elle était dans une robe de taffetas
noir il y avait déjà des sequins
le coup et on a dit cink malik richeux
vos demandes infiniment pardon dit oui
je n'y vois plus rien je n'ai rien à la
une mais l'on m'a cassé mes lunettes
par conséquent nous allons voir comment
nous allons faire le tir à la corde
malheureusement sans lunettes je ne peux
rien faire on va essayer d'y parer par
conséquent nous allons improvisé mais
malheureusement je n'ai plus tout à fait
comme mes moyens
m
sinon que les camerounais sont les
risques du métier les os tomates en dés
et on l'est on va dans des vhu léon
zitrone ne répondait pas ici je vous
appelle de carcassonne à lui que
monsieur vie prend est enfin de se faire
soigner
oui j'ai bien compris mais est ce
qu'elle nous pouvons poursuivre les
messieurs ce qui n'est pas blessé mais
il n'y a rien demandé un crâne est pas
grave ça nous fait mal ça n'est pas
grave dit luc coco fruits dès l'émission
oui oui et je vous demande pardon dit
non ils n'ont pas non plus je voudrais
aussi rassurer des miens qui sont devant
leur écran et leur dire que finalement
en dehors du fait qu'on m'a cassé mes
lunettes et que je n'y vois rien tout va
bien ces deux vieux copains s'appelle
brad hamsik ont argué que toujours
l'équipe de deux points golikova de mac
europe d'ici peu piqué grec dégage
encore secrète mérite une médaille
apple warm up de malte
devant ma télé dakar
ces décorations américaine
absolument commandeur de l'ordre des
anciens combattants américains des
guerres de tranchées et pourquoi la
refuserait ge d'air france
la fabrique l'annoncé un discours
important
si j'avais à donner comme reporter mon
avis sur cette cérémonie
je dirais que celui qui a reçu la
cravate de commandeur a comme d'habitude
par les trop longuement mais que voulez
vous c'est un défaut dont il ne se
débarrassera jamais et le renard ou et
des fêtes sont bien vus 6p n'y est bien
et derrière nos bus et multi
ce prix de la grille on le dit ce n'est
pas gagné le 19 des treuils tous des
points à gagner
deuxième le 13 argument troisième le 8
et la madame ou c'est l'arrivée que je
vous avais annoncé ici longchamp à tous
les programmes avec nous deux autres
invités qui ont rejoint michel drucker
jax albert michel péricard jax albert
c'est vous qui avait initié des onze y
trône au tiercé
non c'est moi qui ai mis le pied à
l'étrier c'est pour moi qui les unit
surgir si c'était moi qui faisais des
courses hippiques chacun sait pas grand
chose mais vous savez on est un peu
n'importe quoi en ce moment là on a un
peu tout et j'en avais un sèche-cheveux
quelqu'un vous vous succéder et il y
avait quelqu'un qui était tout le temps
si à côté de moi quand j'étais à auteuil
et quand c'était un auchan c'était un
monsieur qui s'appelait léon zitrone et
que ça avait déjà rencontré par ce que
il travaillait radio et il était aux
ondes courtes et à ce moment là je dis à
sa bague
je dirai jamais assez de faire les
courses rend donc zitrone
c'est comme ça j'évite on y rentre avec
luz
alors oui cette série car vous vous avez
été d'abord un confrère puis le
directeur de léon zitrone
quel souvenir en gardez vous j'ai là un
témoignage qui vient c'est tombé c'est
celui d'une de ses filles marie dans ce
titre on disait c'était un père
extraordinaire sont ses propres termes
un très grand professionnel mais il
était chiant oui où j'étais peut-être
chiant mais il est est ce que je dis il
était énorme énorme dans tous les sens
du terme
physiquement ses défauts est énorme il
faut lui dire
même aujourd'hui ses qualités étaient
énormes c'était un personnage hors du
commun qui ne pouvait pas laisser
indifférent
est ce que vient de raconter jax albert
sur les courses hippiques
c'est cette méthode qui lui a permis
d'entrer dans ce métier il est est ce
que jacques appelle les ondes courtes
c'était les émissions vers l'étranger
aux champs elysées à la radio au dessus
de nous et où nous travaillons à la
radio avec pierre des gros et je n'ai
tous les jours il dire par quelque chose
pour moi il n'y a rien à faire
je peux aussi bien de transporter une
dépêche et puis à la fin on finit par
s'habituer à sa venue
il s'est mis à travailler et il est allé
à la télévision moi je les naturellement
surtout connu quand j'étais rédacteur en
chef du journal télévisé et il le
présentait alors c'était un présentateur
exceptionnel parce que n'importe quel
sujet pouvait lui être donnée il le
traitait après comme l'a dit mais c'est
vraiment un travail
on imagine par michel on imagine un
personnage comme ça vous a bien fait de
la politique pourquoi n'at-il pas fait
de la politique il aurait à l'avenir en
faire il a failli en faire
je dirais que pratiquement tous les
partis politiques sauf le parti
communiste lui l'ont sollicité pour être
un jour ou l'autre candidat à la
députation et à chaque fois
naturellement ils venaient boire et à
chaque fois je disais je ne crois pas
que tu réussiras aussi bien dans la
politique à la télévision
mieux vaut ne pas le faire je sais pas
si c'est mon conseil qui l'a suivi mais
devait déjeuner avec lui dans trois
jours vous savez on est en été on est
restés très liés c'était un personnage
qui était à la fois énervant et les
revend très con passer devant le pouvoir
très très respectueux des pouvoirs
établis
ce qui pour un journaliste c'est par ici
que je vais le dire vous qui manie est
tellement l'insolence et c'était aussi
une autre position d'une manière fort
aujourd'hui mais il le fait des fois un
peu trop alors il fallait lui redire et
puis dire dans ça va pas merci messieurs
d'avoir témoigné je voudrais simplement
ajouté que dès ce matin le président de
la république monsieur jacques chirac a
publié un communiqué déclarant nous
perdons un grand journaliste
un grand journaliste pardon un immense
professionnel cher au coeur des français
présents à toutes les grandes heures de
télévision son érudition sa rigueur son
enthousiasme était appréciée de chacun
et puis le président de france
télévisions jean pierre elkabbach
déclare que lyon zitrone était et
restera un commentateur inégalée grand
travailleur virtuose du direct qui
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie vécue
intensément sa passion la télévision la
langue je vous dire parler plusieurs
langues et ex tu n'es pas impressionné
tout le monde
la date des obsèques de léon zitrone n'a
pas encore été fixées elles ont lieu à
levallois-perret où il résidait
reportage de michel fille nathalie
gallet ce matin dans son quartier
photo gr qui éventuellement gc la maison
a dit trône là j'avais cherché c'est là
qu'habite la maison ainsi tron est en
face du cimetière de levallois perret il
habitait ici depuis quatre ans à deux
pas de là il y à la fleuriste leon était
le plus célèbre de ses clients d'acheter
quoi beaucoup de roses et de la brasse
il était comment il était gentil très
sympa très décontracté un homme simple
charmant sous ses apparences le mossad
onur square l'homme n'était pas très
expansif dont le quartier on le savait
et on le reste c'est lui mais pour dire
bonjour députés ont réservé un petit peu
c'est amusant pas en face chacun sa
personnalité a enfin c'était quelqu'un
qui avait beaucoup de personnalité c'est
ce qu'ils voulaient c'était de saisie
trône témoin ces derniers temps sa santé
s'était dégradé les voisins le voyez
moins souvent depuis un certain temps on
le voyait avec sa canne et ce matin 6
heures quand j'ai pris europe j'ai
entendu qu'il était décédé shit et rep
et demi est-ce que c'est quelqu'un que
vous connaissez bien qu'ils ne
connaissaient pas léon notre leo leo
sera enterré tout près de chez lui dans
ce cimetière de levallois perret ou
encore jacques salbert pour parler d'une
nouvelle sonne qui a tenu très grande
place dans la vie c'est son époux
terminer je voudrais quand même comment
dans un match formidable à sa femme sa
fille laura j'ai très bien connu que je
me demande qu'à revoir et qui a été
formidable aux produits car vous savez
être la femme de leus sonne c'est pas
facile
merci jacques les autres titres de
l'actualité les perturbations se
poursuivent aujourd'hui à la sncf et le
président de la sncf monsieur
bergougnoux a décidé d'avancer à cet
après-midi la table ronde avec les
syndicats au cours de laquelle doit être
exposé le contrat de plan entre
l'entreprise et l'état jean yves perrin
jean-louis québec le français est à
14h15 a pas de train pour conflans fin
d'oise
dans un article atteint quelques trains
circulent au départ de paris
saint-lazare mais pas forcément celui
qu'on veut un train toutes les heures
pour chaque destination le réseau
banlieue tourne au ralenti et ce n'est
pas le seul toujours à saint lazare
aucun train pour la normandie avant
17h47 au départ de la province même
situation en moyenne un train sur quatre
sauf pour le trafic régional quasi
inexistant la sncf essaie de maintenir
les trains circulant en fin d'après midi
toujours très fréquenté le dimanche soir
l'ampleur du mouvement semble avoir
surpris la direction elle vient
d'avancer la table ronde destinée à
préciser le futur contrat de plan état
sncf à l'ensemble des syndicats de
cheminots
cette table ronde était prévue lundi
matin elle se tiendra dès cet après-midi
15 heures
en bref encore à l'étranger un tout
petit oui au divorce en irlande 9000
voix d'écart pour le oui après avoir été
compté deux fois les bulletins donne
donc la réponse oui au la légalisation
du divorce dans ce pays en bref encore
en france deux policiers blessés par des
voleurs s'est tenu à lyon surpris moment
il défoncé la vitrine d'un magasin avec
leur voiture ils ont foncé sur les
policiers qui les avaient surpris
alain carignon fait appel de sa
condamnation à cinq ans de prison dont
deux avec sursis ajoutons qu'il a essayé
de demander que cet appel ne soit pas
jugé à à la coupe devant la cour d'appel
de lyon et puis juste avant notre
journal monsieur blondel participer à
l'émission
polémique le leader de force ouvrière a
déclaré à cette occasion qu'il avait
rencontré le président de la république
sur le plan de réforme de la sécurité
sociale et qu'à cette occasion il lui
avait menti par omission
le sport maintenant le football le psg
largement en tête après sa victoire
d'hier soir yann lavoix auxerre 2e du
championnat reut sauver guingamp en
rouge
l'étonnant promu qui bien que réduits à
dix après l'expulsion de candé la marque
deux buts coup sur coup
grâce à carnot incroyable guingampais
qui ont signé leur troisième victoire à
l'extérieur auxerre réduit le score
grâce à diomède à dix minutes de la fin
mais s'incline une nouvelle fois
domicile et manque donc l'occasion de
rester seuls deuxièmes au classement
lorsque deux clubs européens se
rencontrent devant quarante deux mille
spectateurs le spectacle est souvent
assurée deux minutes de jeu locaux place
une tête 1-0 pour le psg devant bordeaux
locaux va réussir son premier doublé de
la saison en championnat
en deuxième mi temps c'est lui qui
traîne dans la surface pour tromper
gaëtan huard les bordelais sans doute
émoussés après leur match face à séville
cette semaine vont repartir du parc avec
le tarif psg habituel trois buts dans la
musette
ce dernier réussit par rail son 11e de
la saison
les autres résultats de cette dernière
journée des matches aller metz et nantes
ont fait match nul 0 à 0 11e match sans
défaite pour les nantais lyon peine
toujours en championnat 1 partout face à
lille même score à lens et petit exploit
donc pour cannes
au classement le psg accentue son avance
7 points désormais sur auxerre et metz
guingamp et 5e belle surprise bordeaux
est 14e lyon est 15e étonnante déception
quant aux cannois ils sont désormais
seuls dernier
ce soir nous vous proposerons un journal
de 20h largement consacrée vous en
doutez à la disparition de léon zitrone
avec tous ceux qui l'ont connu pierre
tchernia michel drucker qui reviendra
parmi nous jacques martin et bien
d'autres pour l'heure et puisqu'il ne
reviendra plus du diable vauvert comme
il aimait à le dire lorsqu'il commentait
les courses une dernière fois laissons
le mot de la fin à léon zitrone
maintenant que nous sommes entre nous je
vais vous dire ceci je n'ai jamais
cherché à faire carrière c'est vrai que
je suis à la télévision quant au plus
tôt - tantôt beaucoup moins je suis
depuis plus de 20 ans mais chaque fois
qu'on me demande de venir et d'en faire
eh bien ça me fait très plaisir et je ne
cache pas bonsoir
mais regroupe les mentaires notre mai 68
en guise aisne
aujourd'hui empire du jeu aux 36 68 10
10 tous les résultats
tous les classements bonsoir mesdames
mon sens mesdemoiselles messieurs
monstre un hommage ce soir dans le
journal de 20h à léon zitrone l'un des
grands monstres de la télévision
française
la vie est bien celle au miel avec
derrière et il est terriblement loin
d'andy